[Music]
so scrolls are the bad guys
and you're a free a race of noble
warriors heroes noble warrior heroes
[Music]
your life began the day it nearly ended
we found you with no memory we made you
one of us so you could live longer
stronger superior
you were reborn
I keep having these memories something
in my past is the key to all of this
you're not a bladders thing we'll see
that's a yes or no question
yes
[Music]
would you like to know
what you really are
I think I had a life here
what are you telling me
we've come a long way but you're not as
strong as you think
[Music]
the slaw is just the beginning
I'm not going to fight your war
[Music]
I'm gonna end it
[Music]
[Music]
I've seen the cutest little thing
what's your name
[Music]
[Music]
war than universal language
I know renegade so - mercy never
occurred to me that one might come from
above
space invasion
the car chase
truth be told I was ready to hang it up
to let miss you today so you're not from
around here it's hard to explain
I keep having these memories
I see flashes
[Music]
I think I had a life here
[Music]
but I can't tell if it's real
[Music]
we have no idea what threats are out
there
we can't do this alone
we leave you
I'm not what you think I am
[Music]